one year ago this very day right here in
Star City you missed your intended
target but your arrow found its way into
my boy that is not the actual part he
told me the details of his son's death
he was killed one year ago today Kaden
thinks that he was collateral damage
from a fight that I had in Star City
it's not possible you were in Hub City
recording diner yep hey everybody this
is gonna be my arrow video just careful
for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet there is a new round
of that flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter just be a subscriber and
share the video using those tools on the
watch page but basically you can kind of
see what they're doing they're slowly
revealing who Kate and James son is and
why it is that he thinks that Oliver
killed him there's this big surprise I
feel like they're building towards and
it probably has something to do with
prometheus last year so right now this
is the biggest mystery like what was the
evidence that he sent Kate and James
when Oliver was busy recruiting Dinah I
think it was around episode 10 or
episode 11 it was like right at the
beginning of the second half of arrow
season last year so think about it this
way who died relatively close to that
that Oliver definitely is responsible
for
right now best option for that is Billy
remember Felicity's old boyfriend that
Oliver killed thinking that he was
prometheus so they went through that
whole thing last season but what if Kate
and James was his father then a couple
months after that we get to episode 10
episode 11 he goes to recruit Black
Canary and Prometheus quietly sends Kate
and James that thumb drive with video a
green arrow maybe killing his son so
it's a collateral damage situation they
used that term during the episode but
it's always possible that it's someone
else just current best candidate we know
that Oliver is responsible for killing
Billy and he was a relatively big
character during that season at least
for Felicity's character I never really
connected with him that much but I know
a lot of people are wondering maybe it
might be Roy or another big character
that we already know on the show so he
thinks that he's dead and whatever
evidence is on that thumb drive seems to
imply that so I don't think that that's
being faked I think that Oliver really
was responsible for whoever his son was
but the other big question now is is
what is he going to do with that ten
million dollars that Oliver is wiring to
his offshore account on a regular basis
he said that he has to continue to do
that for the foreseeable future until
they bleed the city dry
so really the drawback of that is that
he's just going to make Oliver seem like
a really bad mayor and he's gonna make
everybody really pissed off with him
with the city so he's gonna wind up
turning into like a season 2 season 3
situation where you just have all-out
war in the streets there were a whole
bunch of Easter eggs and we got that
whole subplot with William 1 they're
giving him this minor hero arc where he
gets to be like Green Arrow and helps
save people like he even saves the bully
that's been torturing him this whole
time but because Oliver and Felicity are
married now they're kind of turning them
into a little family unit and they're
actually doing kind of the same thing on
the flash but they're building that
family unit in a really circuitous way
like you know you see this girl that
might be Barry's daughter I'll talk
about that during a flash video later
today because the end result winds up
being the same thing like you have the
flash family you have like the arrow
family now so William is in the arrow
cave he's checking out all of her stuff
if you saw the trailer that they posted
a while ago - it's him looking at all
these things and being a little more
okay with Oliver being the Green Arrow
which I think was a place we all knew we
were going to Oliver's not gonna stop
being the green arrow and I
think they want a relatively positive
relationship between him and his son so
eventually something was going to have
to happen to make him feel okay with all
of her putting the suit back on and that
was largely what they use Felicity's
character for and now it makes a little
more sense why they've had those
characters spend so much time together
this past season although I think
everybody picked up on that like in the
first couple of episodes like oh she's
tutoring him very clearly they're laying
groundwork for her to become some sort
of stepmom for him but if he didn't spot
it when they were in that tunnel
sequence the buses license plate red Red
Rum which is from The Shining movie so
you could take this Easter egg a number
of different ways one you could take it
as a joke that William is the child from
the shining and he has special powers
he's not a metahuman he doesn't actually
have special powers but you could take
it as a joke on that or you could just
take it as somebody going crazy like
Jack Nicholson from the shining like
just [ __ ] going absolutely bonkers wild
dog had that joke about escape from
Detroit mister terrific got totally
upset with them because he loves John
Carpenter movies escape from New York is
one of my favorite classic John
Carpenter movies but then like probably
the biggest Easter Egg is mister
terrific joking about calling new team
arrow the outsiders which is actually a
title that they thought about using on
one of the shows a long time ago the now
disgraced Andrew Kreisberg was doing an
interview a couple years ago with Kevin
Smith where he talked about them
creating the legends of tomorrow TV show
and they were thinking about what to
title it like what is this going to be
are we gonna call it just the society
can we call it JSA can we call it The
Outsiders he said the big reason that
they decided not to use the outsiders
name is because that's mostly thought of
is a Batman title like Batman and the
outsiders and there was no way that
Batman was going to be a character on
that so they didn't want to do something
like The Outsiders without actually
doing the characters from that title or
do Justice Society without doing legit
Justice Society characters
we're the Justice Society of America and
you're coming with us
[Music]
we really only got them for a couple
episodes during season two a legend so
hopefully at some point in a couple
years maybe down the road they'll do an
actual Justice Society TV show they have
revealed a couple things about the next
couple of episodes they don't offer any
evidence as to who Kate and James Sun is
but Roy is coming back I think episode
15 they're taking all kinds of pictures
behind the scenes Paul Blackthorne has
been posting pictures from previous
seasons when Roy is still in the costume
they're doing some usual suspects
episode 13 is titled the devil's
greatest trick that might have something
to do with Oliver convincing everyone
that he's not the Green Arrow or it
might be something specific to the Kate
and James character or the villain
episode 12 is gonna be Oliver versus
Black Canary I don't know how much of a
fight they're going to have but they're
just teasing a conflict I think the
closest that the two teams would get to
actually fighting each other would be
harsh words and a bit of a slap fight I
don't think that anybody's gonna put
anybody in the hospital but it was
actually pretty cool to watch Black
Canary stop the train with her sonic
scream it gives you an idea for how
powerful she is it looked like she was
opening up a hundred percent on that
they actually did a character that had a
similar ability called banshee from the
comics on Supergirl
who was actually able to levitate
herself with her sonic scream so maybe
at some point they'll try having Black
Canary jump off of a building and use
her sonic scream to cushion the blow I
don't think it would totally work but as
long as the building wasn't too high she
could probably eat that but let me know
in the comments who do you think the
Kate and James Sun is in how big of a
part of this do you think the prometheus
is like he's hurting Oliver from beyond
the grave like even though he was dead
there were a lot of things that he set
in motion that would be hurting Oliver
during season six and this just feels
like one of those things but what'll
happen next is I'll do a video for that
dawn West character on the flash and
talk about iris West getting powers the
CW finally confirmed officially why
she's going to be wearing a speedster
costume and it's gonna be temporary but
I'll explain it'll all make sense it's
loading
on loading loading loading loading and
it says this house is spittin we're
gonna need more diapers so I'll name the
giveaway winner when I post that video
click here for brand new flash and click
here for brand new black panther footage
and avengers thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome i'll see
you guys tonight